et place aux grands débats politiques de
cette émission avec deux soutiens des
candidats merci messieurs d'avoir
accepté de débattre clément bonne soit
atteint d'état aux affaires européennes
soutien des manuels macron merci d'être
là et laurent jacot bélie porte parole
de marine le pen merci d'être là
également on va évidemment revenir sur
les thèmes du débat mais d'abord est-ce
que selon vous qu'est mans bonne ce
débat est de nature à inverser le
rapport de force électoral qui pour le
moment dans les sondages je parle bien
des sondages est al avantage d manueel
macron est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que vous avez réussi à faire déplacer
des voix à gagner des voix
supplémentaires ça je me garderai bien
de tout pronostic en la matière les
français voteront dimanche et il ya un
entre-deux tours dont ce débat était un
moment fouillé détail est important
c'était important parce que c'est un
rituel républicain depuis près de 50 ans
qui a permis vision vie contre vision
projet contre projet de manière précise
malheureusement pas sur tous les thèmes
mais sur des thèmes très important sur
le pouvoir d'achat sur l'europe sur
l'écologie de clarifier un certain
nombre de malentendus je crois qu'ils
avaient beaucoup d'incohérences dans le
projet de même le pen qui ont été
démasqués on y reviendra mais d'exposer
des visions opposées très opposées mais
dans un climat de sérénité et avec la
possibilité pour chacun moi j'en ai
rencontré beaucoup ces derniers jours
qu'ils attendaient le débat pour se
faire un avis définitif donc le crois
que c'était utile lors jacquot bélier ou
est-ce que puisque marine le pen et
parlement retard dans les sondages est
clair vous avez l'impression qu'elle a
pu gagner des voix et inversait la
tendance écoutez en tout cas c'était
l'objectif aussi de ce débat il ya eu on
le sait beaucoup de personnes qui sont
indécises pour le choix du second tour
et ce débat avait pour objectif de leur
montrer deux visions de la france celle
du candidat emmanuel macron celle de
marine le pen deux personnalités aussi
qu'ils se sont fait jour hier entre une
candidate sereine calme déterminé et un
président qui est parfois un peu
arrogant un peu condescendant il y as je
croyais rue des éléments de programme
très clair deux visions de la france une
france
généreuse solidaire fraternelle fière
d'elle-même et en face une france qui
regarde toujours plus ailleurs que sur
son propre sol fédéraliste mondialistes
les projets se sont affrontés et je vous
rejoins pour dire qu'il y avait je crois
une certaine tenue à ce débat il ya eu
quelques quelques écarts quelques
tentatives de la part du candidat macron
de déstabilisation l'on va dire que
c'est le jeu mais que globalement
les questions ont été posées et que le
fonds a pu être évoqué je pense que
c'est un vrai outil de décision pour
beaucoup de français qui ne savent pas
je ne savais pas pour qui voter dimanche
clément valla réponse sur la forme
pas commentait éternellement marine le
pen a été gêné par un stand le sujet il
ya des silences éloquents sur le co vide
elle n'a pas su dire ce qu'elle aurait
fait quand l'assemblée ne découvrira ce
interne de ces mesures sur
l'augmentation des professeurs par
exemple mais peu importe je crois qu'on
a eu plus de deux heures et demie où les
français ont pu juger de la compétence
où je crois parfois des difficultés à
expliquer chez marine le pen de deux
visions différentes en effet sur le
voile sur l'europe sur le climat où il
n'y a pas d'ambiguïté sur les
oppositions entre une vision vous l'avez
présenter à votre manière sur la
question européenne je crois qu'on a
bien vu que marine le pen n'avait
toujours pas de projet et qu'elle avait
des pma l'écouter son fric citant petit
bout mais on va le rediscuter j'imagine
mal en tout cas on a eu un moment
important de clarté démocratique qui
trois heures c'est probablement un peu
lourd et peut-être avez-vous eu quelques
moments de décrochage mais je crois que
sur la question j'ai bien écouté
européenne marine auclair ait marine le
pen pardon a été très clair excusez moi
c'est un peu la fatigue après débat elle
a été claire elle a dit que vous avez
une vision assez binaire des choses
quand je dis vous c'est votre candidat
et si longtemps soit on accepte tout
l'union européenne sans sourciller soit
on rejette tout en bloc et bien marine
le pen pense qu'il ya une voie entre les
deux c'est à dire qu'on peut vouloir
travailler avec nous nos partenaires à
27 choisir les sujets sur lesquels on
travaille corriger ce qui ne fonctionne
pas comme par exemple le contrôle
de l'immigration qui ne marche pas et
puis en même temps essayer de faire
évoluer les choses vous savez emmanuel
macron lui-même d'ailleurs lorsqu'il
faisait encore des promesses aux
français et qu'il a montré après qu'il
ne l'ait réalisait pas disait qu' ils
voulaient échanger cette union
européenne il disait à l'époque avec
madame merkel même renégocier certains
traités ils nous l'avons fait il ne l'a
pas fait et on revient sur les points
essentiels
aujourd'hui marine le pen ne dit pas
autre chose je crois que la preuve la
différence entre les deux c'est qu'elle
elle le fera elle le sera parce que son
objectif premier c'est de défendre la
france et les français et que l'union
européenne serve aussi à l'intérêt des
français on a l'impression que emmanuel
macron et dans le l'objectif inverse
d'adapter les français à marche forcée à
ce que veulent les commissaires
européens et imposer la vision de
bruxelles aux français ce deux visions
je le répète tout à fait différente les
deux étant estimable est-ce qu'on peut
changer l'europe sans en sortir c'est le
débat hier soir l'europe qui change
c'est celle que on est en train de
construire ah bon oui on peut prendre
des exemples au député européen je
regrette qu'ils soient souvent absent de
ces débats mais bon mais gardons à
certains niveaux ou alors on a souvent
débattu ensemble enfin plusieurs mais je
vais répondre oui mais il ya toujours eu
je sais je crois à risques mais laisser
déraper papa de pas de fouler ses
vérités parce que c'est un engagement
pour changer l'europe vous pouvez
regarder les taux de présence il vient
de loin que notre groupe est
probablement aidé à définir la manière
pour le sujet donc ne dira pas ce genre
de journée voilà l'europe qui change
c'est celle qu'on est en train de
construire je le maintiens parce que on
a été d'ailleurs évoqué hier parfois
soyons précis sur la réforme du travail
des tâches et on l'a fait c'est là
dessus que je prends cet exemple précis
pas seulement la russie monsieur jacques
aubé dit contrairement à ce que vous
pouviez imaginer où on n'a pas eu le
soutien tant mieux si maintenant vous
pensez que la réforme serait les tâches
étaient une europe qui change et qui est
nécessaire parce que ce ne sont pas
suffisants mais sa lutte contre le
dumping social l'imposition des grandes
multinationales
on est en train de le faire au niveau
européen et international je veux dire
par là c'est que moi je ne suis pas du
tout dans l'idée que l'europe tel qu'on
l'a connu il ya cinq ans et même encore
aujourd'hui est parfaite et doit être
prise en bloc pas du tout simplement
puisque vous dites vous prendre au avoir
un projet d'amélioration et le
changement de l'europe il faut quand
même dire comment on fait il faut aller
au bout du raisonnement sur la
contribution au budget de l'union
européenne par exemple on a tous envie
de payer moins de recevoir plus c'est
clair mais si vous êtes dans une
copropriété dans un club à 27 il n'y a
pas beaucoup de solutions soit vous ne
négociez vouloir négocier c'est ce que
vous semblez vouloir faire je rappelle
que ce budget il était négocié il ya
deux ans vous avez pris l'exemple de
pays comme les pays bas je crois qu'ils
ont obtenu une ristourne sur leur budget
européen c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
c'est en échange de politiques qu'on a
maintenu notamment pour nos agriculteurs
dont vous n'aurez pas le beurre et
l'argent du beurre pas parce que
l'europe est technocratique mais parce
que dans une collectivité ça fonctionne
comme ça quand vous dites ça paraît
aussi dit comme ça un bon sens
sympathique on va faire primer toujours
le droit français sur le droit européen
problème c'est quand vous avez des
règles collectives s'avouant société et
l'europe est une société d'état
souverain
quand tu le prends 10 les règles qu'on a
défini ensemble moi je les respecte
quand ça m'arrange c'est comme si les
plus la règle commune donc ce que je
vous reproche n'est pas de vouloir
changer l'europe
ça c'est la présentation habile que vous
essayez de faire depuis quelques jours
c'est le cash est en réalité un projet
qui va des facteurs à l'abri mais je
prends le dernier exemple je vous laisse
répondre vers le marché européen de
l'électricité
oui il a plein de défauts nous confirme
j'en suis parfaitement conscient c'est
nous qui avons lancé ce sujet à
l'automne dernier parfois un peu seul en
france et en europe on est en train
d'arriver le réformer le prix de la
république l'a dit hier pan mais si vous
coupez les fils si vous débrancher la
prise ça c'est une sortie ça fait partie
des éléments de sortie de l'union
européenne qui me préoccupe beaucoup
parce que c'est aussi l'intérêt des
consommateurs français avoir une
connexion aux autres pays européens
alors il ya beaucoup de sujets sains de
ce que vous avez évoqué j'essayais de
d'échanger avec vous parce que
clairement on voit bien la fracture
entre nous sur cette vision du travail à
27 me vois plutôt une europe des nations
où on défend les nations et où ils
travaillent ensemble sur des projets
communs vous voyez un trait de craie
voyez plutôt un fédéralisme repéra la
france devenant une espèce de région les
tenants de cette europe devant appliquer
ce que vont jamais union en fait on se
sent seul à décider sur des points très
concrets vous parliez des pays bas et de
la ristourne bah oui ce que les pays-bas
ont fait je ne vois pas pourquoi la
france n'y arriverait pas vous savez
mais si on y réussit
je ne faisais pas interrompu si demain
vous me donnez 100 euros et que je vous
envoie sentent
vous je pourrais vous dire du effet un
cadre un cadeau de 60 euros au final je
pense que je vous aurais arnaquer de 40
et bien aujourd'hui quand on donne 24
milliards au budget c'est une
contribution au budget européen et qu'on
en reçoit 14 et bien il y à 9 milliards
d'écart 9 milliards de déficit pour les
contribuables français ce que dit marine
le pen ce n'est pas que nous allons
arrêter d'avoir une contribution
positive parce que la france est un pays
fort et qu'il ya une forme de devoir de
solidarité entre les pays européens mais
c'est que nous allons réduire cette
contribution c'est à dire qu'au lieu
d'avoir un déficit de neuf milliards il
sera seulement 2,4 milliards c'est à la
fois raisonnable et c'est protéger les
intérêts des français croyez moi c'est 5
milliards de différence dans l'état où l
hôpital aujourd'hui dans l'état où ils
sont les prestations prestations
sociales aujourd'hui dans l'état où elle
emploie aujourd'hui les français en ont
besoin et puis il ya un autre échec de
l'union européenne et cet échec là nous
voulons vraiment vraiment le confronter
à la réalité et faire des propositions
c'est l'immigration il faut le dire
frontex qui est censée protéger les
frontières de l'europe ça ne fonctionne
pas ça marche pas on rentre européenne
on rentre en union européenne comme dans
un moulin nous sommes victimes
d'ailleurs des politiques migratoires de
nos pays voisins quand l'allemagne
décide de recevoir un million de
migrants c'est la décision du
gouvernement allemand et je la respecte
c'est la décision du peuple allemand et
nous la respectons
en revanche quand un de ces migrants met
le pied sur le sol allemand à partir de
ce moment là il peut aller en france et
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est l'effet que
ça s'il faut une politique européenne
s'est défait de sas les diplômés qui
trouvent un travail en allemagne reste
en allemagne les autres viennent toucher
les allocations et les aides sociales en
france il faut donc renforcer frontex
pour les frontières extérieures et il
m'a zonage ce que nous sommes il faut
contrôler les frontières intérieures
françaises pour les non résidents de
l'union européenne pour protéger
l'économie française et la sécurité des
français c'est là qu'on voit sur le fond
je suis sur le fond des contradictions
et pardon des incohérences vous 10 et
être cohérent n'étant pas d'accord avec
vous mais c'était important de montrer
la plénitude des projets et donc
allons-y sur la contribution je veux pas
être trop long évidemment encore une
fois on préfère payer un peu moins mais
c'est une négociation qui a lieu tous
les sept ans donc vous irez revoir le
partenaire européen en disant c'était il
ya deux ans à l'époque dans cette
hypothèse où marine le pen serait telus
dimanche soir nous n'étions pas au
pouvoir vous diraient nos partenaires
européens donc on rouvre tout ça ça va
pas beaucoup leur plaire mais admettons
vous savez ce qu'on a en face un certain
nombre de rabais de ristournes ya
beaucoup de plus et de moins on a une
politique agricole commune on lève le
plan de relance européen majeur soyez
cohérents vous nous dites c'est pas
logique qu'on donne 100 milliards et
qu'on reçoit 60 pas tout à fait ça les
chiffres mais on est en effet
contributeurs nets au budget l'union
européen pourquoi fait la moitié du
chemin oka vous accepter la logique mais
un peu comment vous allez expliquer ça à
nos partenaires je vous rappelle aussi
que les pays qu'on aide par cette
solidarité européenne la pologne la
hongrie que vous aimez bien d'habitude
ce sont des marchés pour nos entreprises
un emploi sur dix en france c'est lié au
marché unique je prends l'exemple parce
qu'il est très intéressant sur les
migrations d'abord tant mieux je le dis
sincèrement sur le fond vous avez bouger
sur ce sujet vous ne vouliez pas
entendre parler de frontex par le site
vous députés sur le fond et vous ne
voulez pas entendre parler de politique
européenne d'immigration vous dit
exactement d'ailleurs ce qu'on a dit il
ya cinq ans sur le diagnostic il n'y a
pas de politique européenne d'asile et
d'immigration qui fonctionne si on ne
travaille pas tous ensemble s'appelle
chaque politique dans son coin parce
qu'en l'effet qu'on rentre en grèce en
allemagne on rentre sur le sol européen
et c'est ça le problème mais feront le
texte qu'on a créé ce mécanisme pour
ceux qui nous écoutent ça peut être
compliqué c'est police des frontières
européennes il faut l'améliorer on est
en train de voter un budget que vous
n'avez pas soutenu pour avoir dix mille
hommes dans frontex qui vont permettre
de renforcer le contrôle aux frontières
la pologne on peut pas accuser la
fédéralisme échevelé vous en conviendrez
vous aimez bien le gouvernement polonais
actuelle elle a reconnu elle même par la
voix sont prêts ministe que si elle pas
eu d'actions européennes dans ces
derniers mois diplomatique pour
suspendre les vols qui venait de
biélorussie pour mettre la pression à
ses frontières c'est plus de
coordination européenne elle n'aurait
pas su faire face à cette pression
migratoire c'est précisément pour ça
qu'il nous faut une politique européenne
et je finis juste sur un point parce que
ça c'est très important sur la cohérence
pour le présenter positivement vous nous
dites il faut police des frontières
européennes très bien soutenez nous et
il faut aussi des contrôles aux
frontières intérieures absolument dans
quelle mesure parce que j'ai entendu
votre collègue monsieur venu expliquer
que ça s'appliquait aussi aux
marchandises peut s'appliquer aux
mouvements du quotidien avec des petits
drones qui survoleront les camions à la
frontière avec l'allemagne c'est ce
qu'il a dit des drones des moyens
modernes at il dit c'est ce que disaient
les breaks sitter d'ailleurs sur la
frontière intelligente pour contrôler la
circulation vous allez expliquer à nos
entreprises qui font des milliards de
chiffre d'affaires en exportant parce
qu'on est un pays fort en europe à nos
agriculteurs qui exportent en europe
massivement que chaque camion va être
contrôlé par un petit drone ou par un
douanier je l'expliqué aussi à 150
millions d'alliés si je peux si je peux
vous répondre parce que là vous
attendrez les est entré dans un tunnel
monsieur bolduc forme de question
qu'elle aux frontaliers
il n'y avait pas eu de bons titres les
téléspectateurs auraient compris que
vous étiez soutien d' emmanuel macron
parce que vous allez déjà sûrs lors de
notre entretien aujourd'hui plusieurs
fois recours au mensonge vous venez de
parler on avait dit qu'on reste énorme
effort je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
vous parlez des importations dit la
vérité à nos téléspectateurs aujourd'hui
la balance commerciale de la france
c'est-à-dire la différence entre ce que
nous importons est ce que nous exportons
est historiquement négatif à - 85
milliards d'euros car s'ils viennent pas
dormi les anciens murs qui viennent pas
sur eux une fois encore je ne vous
interdis en fait si vous imaginez que
tout cela est satisfaisant
grand bien vous fasse nous nous estimons
que ce n'est pas normal vous parliez du
contrôle aux frontières des produits oui
quand nous imposons à un agriculteur
français un certain nombre de normes sur
les pesticides sur les méthodes
d'irrigation et c'est tout à fait normal
nous l'assumons c'est notre modèle alors
nous exigeons que tous les produits qui
viendront concurrencer les produits
produit par cet agriculteur c'est vrai
au sens de l'art industriel de respecte
les mêmes normes or aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas avec un certain nombre de
traités de libre échange auquel vous
déplacer à l'extérieur d'union
participer et bien aujourd'hui à l'inter
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui nos industriels
nous agriculteurs se trouve en
concurrence déloyale avec des produits
qui respectent pas les mêmes dans votre
sérieux votre idée baptisé vous avez osé
nous qui avons refusé les accords de
libre échange avec l'extérieur j'aurais
pu vous répondre sur frontex a relayé
les frontières intérieures frontex dont
le directeur s'est fait tirer les
oreilles parce qu'il avait osé
arraisonné un bateau de migrants
clandestins et on lui a dit que son rôle
c'était d accueillir qu'il avait
d'ailleurs envoyé le 10 le france la
commission européenne en fallait les
autorités auraient pas la france mais
vous seriez aussi vous le souvenir vous
semblez vous semblez tressé des louanges
à frontex ce n'est pas notre cas un
dernier mot sur sa voie européenne et
internationale un mot sur la russie
alors pour le coup il ya eu un point
d'accord un lien un point d'accord entre
vous entre emmanuel macron et marine le
pen sur la gestion diplomatique
d'emmanuel macron les efforts méritent
d'être soutenus c'est ce que vous dites
laurent jacobellis et ce que dit marine
le pen ya un désaccord en revanche sur
la question des sanctions est ce que
vous entendez les réticences de marine
le pen et de leurs engins kobenni sur
l'embargo sur le gaz et le pétrole russe
commet alors les sanctions jeukam
expliqué il y en a beaucoup on appelle
des paquets de sanction des mesures de
sanctions qui sont prises contre les
oligarques russes des secteurs
économiques proches du pouvoir russe
depuis le début de l'invasion suis
satisfait que marine le pen et apporter
enfin une solidarité c'est clair mais
jamais pareil on pourra regarder ce qui
se passe au parlement permet regardant
les sanctions il ya beaucoup de
sanctions depuis plus d'un mois donc je
comprends que vous les soutenez aussi la
question savoir s'il y en a d'autres qui
vont venir il faut être très clair si on
est dans cette même logique que vous
semblez soutenir de mettre la pression
sur la russie de donner un prix à cette
guerre pour que monsieur poutine on
n'est pas naïfs ne veut pas arrêter du
jour au lendemain mais puisse avoir une
fragilisation de son système militaire
pour que peut-être ces plans les plus
dramatiques il consisterait à accélérer
encore son offensive en ukraine a
peut-être aller
chercher une agression vers d'autres
pays européens c'était possible au début
du conflit tout cela soit ralenties
empêcher freinée par les sanctions et
donc oui la question l'énergie se pose
évidemment il faut l'assumer on l'a déjà
fait sur le charbon donc si vous
soutenez les derniers paquet de
sanctions légales charbon et oui sur le
pétrole il faudra sans doute le faire
dans les prochaines semaines ça se
décide à l'unanimité
donc la france n'est pas dans un système
fédéraliste en l'occurrence où elle
serait écrasée par les autres celui ou
celle qui sera en charge des
responsabilités dans quelques jours ou
quelques semaines pourra décider
librement donc j'ai entendu beaucoup de
théories sur les plans cache externe ces
fossés transparence et sur la table oui
il faudra des sanctions sur le pétrole
russe est probablement à terme sur le
gaz russe je l'assumé parce qu'on peut
pas dire à la fois on soutient un effort
diplomatique qui est de l'ukraine et qui
tape sur la russie et ne pas vouloir
cela simplement c'est d'ailleurs le
débat sur le pouvoir d'achat on l'a fait
à chaque étape
déjà sur les prix d'énergie
reconnaître d'accord sur le fond eh bien
il faudra préserver bien sûr le pouvoir
d'achat des français à chaque fois qu'il
ya des sanctions
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
sur la première partie de votre
intervention je souscris à 100% sur
l'embargo sur un certain nombre de
transactions qui concerne les oligarques
et les proches du pouvoir parce qu'il ya
un objectif c'est la paix il ya un
agresseur c'est la russie il ya un
peuple agressé c'est le peuple ukrainien
et vous savez à quel point nous sommes
attachés à l'indépendance des états et à
leur souveraineté et donc nous devons
défendre l'entendre non l'indépendance
de l'ukraine et sa souveraineté là où je
ne vous rejoint pas c'est que les
mesures que vous annoncez notamment sur
le pétrole et le gaz russe peuvent sur
le papier sembler séduisante semblé
faire montre de bonnes intentions et
d'efficacité mais qu'est ce qui va se
passer il va se passer que évidemment il
y aura un renchérissement du pétrole et
du gaz et donc d'une manière générale
des biens énergétiques ce
renchérissement jeunes cassent sur ce
renchérissement monsieur va coûter cher
aux français des français qui sont déjà
au niveau du porte-monnaie complètement
exergue il ya beaucoup de français je
vais terminer mon propos vraiment joué
un premier changement c'est important de
s'écouter vous dit les chiffres les
français aujourd'hui hésitent à faire le
plein d'essence même pour aller
travailler certains disent et même des
artisans qui ne s'y retrouvent plus
tellement l'essence est chère tellement
ça pollue leur quotidien tellement sa
grève leur budget nous allons encore
aggravée ça nous allons encore
poussée des français vers la précarité
mais qu'est ce qui va se passer du côté
russe parce que ne soyons pas naïfs est
ce que vous croyez que le russe les
russes vont arrêter de vendre le pétrole
dont ils vont trouver de nouveaux
débouchés de même que pour le gaz et
qu'est-ce qui va pas se passer vous
allez renforcer les liens de la russie
avec d'autres puissances l'effet à moyen
terme c'est un renchérissement du coût
de la vie pour les français et c'est une
alliance sino russes ou d'un certain
nombre de pays comme l'inde avec la
russie qui vont créer un pôle encore
plus puissant et qui demain sera encore
plus dangereux économiquement et
peut-être même vous avez raison
diplomatiquement alors faisons preuve de
bon sens je sais que ce mot n'est pas le
premier mot qui vous vient à l'esprit en
général en macro ni mais faisons preuve
c'est jacobellis faisons preuve de bon
sens de l'honnêteté oui oui allons vers
la paix vraiment allons-y et comment et
allons allons il parla des glacis
allons-y par la diplomatie mais des
mesures qui n'ont pas d'effet et qui
nuisent aux français non on vous parlait
de 2014 tout à l'heure il ya eu des
mesures d'embargo alimentaire
d'exploitation alimentaires vers la
russie qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce sont
nos agriculteurs qui en ont pâti
certaines exploitations ont été obligés
de fermer et les russes ont mis le
paquet en investissement sur leur propre
production la russie s'en est retrouvé
renforcer nos agriculteurs sont sont
retrouvé affaibli
quelques mots c'est très important parce
que là aussi ces projets contre-projet
il est question de cohérence la réalité
c'est que vous n'adhérez pas aux
sanctions parce que le v6 contraire
monsieur mais pardon mais parce que
sinon il faut être cohérent en 2014
d'ailleurs parlé des sanctions qui ont
été mises à l'époque elles ont fait
l'objet de compensations financières la
vérité c'est que vous étiez ce style
déjà aux sanctions puisque n'est pas
reconnu l'agression russe en crimée
relisez les techniciens avaient c'est
vrai alors se former à rideaux et donc
là les sentiments de retrait là les
sanctions économiques qui sont déjà
mises en place si votre seule clé de
lecture c'est l'impact sur le pouvoir
d'achat par parenthèse les prix de
l'énergie avaient commencé augmenter
avant la guerre ce n'est pas le seul
facteur c'est bien pour ça qu'on a pris
bien avant le 24 février et le début de
l'agression des mesures importantes de
protection du point de choc nous
continuerons il faut être cohérent faut
pas raconter des carabistouilles gens ça
existe pas la mesure où fait pression
sur la russie il n'y a pas d'impact pour
nous n'existe pas sinon soyez cohérent
dit que ce qui épate des sanctions
contre les oligarques aujourd'hui dit
que les sanctions économiques sur des
secteurs comme l'acier sur des secteurs
comme le charbon il faut l'élever soyez
cohérent parce que ça aussi un impact
sur le pouvoir d'achat sinon parlerai
pas de ce débat sur le pouvoir d'achat
en france aujourd'hui nous nous disons
parce que c'est la guerre sur notre
continent parce que nous avons tous vu
les massacres de boue de chat eh bien
oui bien sûr on devra renforcer les
sanctions contre la russie ce serait
mentir que de dire le contraire ou alors
ça veut dire qu'on assume de ne plus
peser et compris démocrates et
diplomatiquement dans ce conflit les
sanctions sont le seul outil de pression
efficace il ya un élément tiers des
efforts diplomatiques vis est là dans le
lot mais vous l'avez saluer vous jamais
et on l'a dit non mais attendez nous
protège droit d'être honnête intelligent
comme amel dans sa xsara a été capable
de dire je finis lassus personne est
incapable de dire de votre côté j'ai
entendu monsieur bachleda parler
d'explosion des prix à la pompe oui de
combien on parle sous sait quel est le
pourcentage de nos explose importe de
pétrole qui viennent de russie lit très
faibles ont bien non vous me posez une
bourse
danger de même que le gars c'est 20% de
mémoire à 17% sur le restant sur le
pétrole puisque le gaz n'est pas encore
complètement débat c'est très faible
part des prix à la pompe donc faire
croire que c'est ça qui va déterminer
faire baisser ou faire augmenter prêt
avant ça n'est pas vrai et quoi qu'il
arrive nous prendrons des mesures de
boucliers tarifaires comme nous l'avons
fait d'ailleurs madame le pen a dit pour
la première fois je crois parce qu'elles
avaient voté contre aussi que le boucler
tarifaire l'était pour en matière
pouvoir d'achat et que ces mesures en
fait ne les remplaçait pas messi a
ajouté j'ai envie de parler de pouvoir
d'achat parce que justement
ça tombe très bien mais c'est la
préoccupation majeure des français ouais
parce qu'après faut vraiment parce que
jordan est un débat intéressant sur la
russie et l'ukraine et je vous en
remercie le reste aussi oui bien
évidemment moi ya quelque chose qui m'a
frappé ce sont les révélations du new
york times qui nous a expliqué qu' un
certain nombre de fonctionnaires
européens mettaient l'embargo sur le
pétrole de côté n'en parlez pas tout de
suite parce que ça aurait pu nuire à la
réélection des manuels macron là je suis
choquée je suis choqué face de
l'ingérence dans notre des pilotes de
d'un entre démocratie mais tous vos
réactions ce qui montre bien qu'ils
pensent que marine le pen sera
négociateurs bout ou plus fermé beaucoup
plus dur pour défendre l'intérêt des
français etc et manu assis le frère
de cette ingérence autres sachent ok
monsieur jacques aubé dit je suis
demandé à monsieur bardella et aux
autres députés européens de vérifier
leurs travaux
c'est sur la table c'est pas le new york
times il a fallu vous alliez lire le new
york times donc le new york times est
des états unis oui alors mondement enfin
été vous savez vous avez lu on peut
chacun peut le regarder c'est en ligne
il faut être le traduire il fait à des
sources européennes qui dirait qu'on a
décidé on décidera après l'élection
présentielle c'est connu la question du
pétrole et du gaz russe on peut avoir un
différend de fond on voulait pas taxer
davantage et même des sanctions
davantage sur les secteurs économiques
russes ça vous c'est votre droit nous
voulons ne pas exclure cette option
c'est notre devoir je crois à l'égard de
l'ukraine et de là aussi mais elle n'est
pas convoqué un quelconque complot c'est
public c'est pas un complice et le
public et si l'offre si j'allais lancer
si j'allais au bout de votre
raisonnement l'union européenne ferait
voter ça juste avant l'élection
présentielle si elle craignait tant que
marine le pen s'y oppose le 25 avril
devrait justement parler du pouvoir
d'achat c'est de cette préoccupation
majeure des français vous promettez des
hausses de salaires vous
marine le pen non parce que nous ne
pensons pas enfin oui et non mais
vous aussi vous pouvez avoir dépensé
complexe
ce n'est pas au rôle n'était plus tôt
sur salaire contre eux prime mais
précisé ce n'est pas au rôle de l'état
de fixer les salaires nous ne sommes pas
en union soviétique ça ne vous aura pas
échappé nous croyons nous à l'économie
de marché à la liberté de décision en
revanche l'état peut avoir un rôle
incitatif
d'où la mesure de marine le pen qui est
de dire aux chefs d'entreprise si vous
emploi si vous augmentez vos salariés de
10% et bien c'est 10% là seront exonérés
de charges patronales pourquoi cette
mesure parce que c'est un marché gagnant
gagnant gagnant litanie perd pas parce
que c'est un manque à gagner peut-être
mais ça ne réduit pas ses ressources et
ses impacts sur le fils deuxièmement
deuxièmement les salariés et c'est bien
évident et gagne troisièmement les chefs
d'entreprises y gagne parce que beaucoup
de chefs d'entreprise aimerait augmenter
un certain nombre de salaires pour
attirer à eux des français pour des
postes vacants mais ne le font pas à
cause du poids exorbitant en france des
taxes et des charges et bien salée
libera ça redonnera pouvoir d'achat aux
français ça redonnera de l'attractivité
à l'emploi et quand on a 5 7 millions de
chômeurs en france aujourd'hui c'est à
dire exactement le même nombre que à
l'arrivée d' emmanuel macron au pouvoir
c'est une mesure nécessaire pour
relancer la machine
d'accord et un désaccord implicite le
point d'accord c'est que évidemment la
question du pouvoir d'achat est centrale
évidemment la meilleure politique du
pouvoir d'achat c'est l'emploi et c'est
le salaire et donc il faut donner une
forme de coup de pouce d'ailleurs il
faut le faire pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes c'est vrai aussi pour les
fonctionnaires tout à fait engagé à
revaloriser le point c'est vrai pour nos
retraités ce n'est pas une mesure
proposée par marine le pen nous avons
proposé d'avancer l'indexation sur
l'inflation au 1er juillet c'est plus de
4% potentiel mandela lui pour le coup
nous proposons depuis le début notre
brave dame à la réindexation des
retraites et pensions mais à partir de
quand partir dès que possible
nous sommes face à un corps et lui ça ne
vous aura pas échappé il est très
patient mais c'est dans 3 je suis vous
inquiétez pas je suis une patience
infinie mais parce que marine le pen à
redire ne savait pas détaillé qu'un bris
mais sur le fond il ya deux mesures qui
sont assez différentes mais qu'on le
même esprit marine le pen après avoir
hésité a reconnu que ces mesures de 10%
était une mesure aléatoire puisque ça
dépendra des choix des entreprises nous
avons la même logique avec la prime dite
macron que nous proposons
significativement d'augmenter en
complément les autres catégories
retraités fonctionnaires qui doivent
aussi avoir un pouvoir d'achat
revaloriser la différence puisqu'il ce
débat je ne sais pas s'il a été très
clair pour les téléspectateurs pérenne
ap renton c'est que quand on rajoute des
choses aux salaires en quelque sorte
notamment une période et une forte
inflation c'est légitime il faut que ça
dépendent dans les choix des entreprises
aussi leur situation économique
notamment pour les plus petites
entreprises assure ainsi vous dit
directement va augmenter pour toujours
les salaires de 10% et l'année prochaine
il ya une difficulté économique eh bien
je crois que ce ne sera pas tenable et
vous détruire et de l'emploi et puis un
point où j'irai imagine tout de suite et
c'est vraiment important mais pour lui
assurer c'est une philosophie une
politique de pouvoir d'achat politique
de points d'achat c'est complet j'ai
évoqué les retraites et les
fonctionnaires ou je crois qu'on est
très clair mais c'est aussi un certain
nombre de mesures qui vont soutenir sur
les produits qui augmentent le plus
notamment les maires le pouvoir d'achat
à très court terme
alors je reviens pas c'est très
important ça la différence entre la tva
et l'échec comme vous l'avez vous êtes
dans une politique de l'instant nous on
essaye d'être dans une politique du long
terme je vous explique il ya un problème
économique vous fait un chèque j'ai bien
trouvé c'est un chèque achète
consommation
les salaires vous faites des primes mais
ça veut dire quoi une prime c'est
aléatoire en tout cas dans le temps
serait à tenir avec ce volet retraites
vous savez chaque année les français
aujourd'hui le mécanisme externe ils
préparent leur budget à l'euro près pour
l'appliquer en tout cas les classes
moyennes les classes les plus
défavorisées quelques uns s'en sortent
très bien il peut vous dire merci mais
la plupart ont un problème pour
différents bien avec vous le savez quand
on fait son bilan mensuel recettes
dépenses c'est à l'euro près on a besoin
de savoir combien on va gagner dans les
mois qui viennent on va on a besoin de
savoir combien on va dépenser besoin de
se projeter dans l'avenir c'est pour ça
que nous nous proposons des mesures
pérennes marine le pen quand elle
proposait d'augmentation oui on ne
pourra pas revenir en arrière de cette
augmentation mais c'est important pour
savoir qu à quel niveau sera la retraite
effet nos services sont garantis ce qui
va arriver demain quand elle propose que
nos jeunes de moins de 30 ans soit
exonérée de l'impôt sur le revenu je
sais que vous allez encore me sortir le
nom de kylie à lemba paix mais vous
savez il ya des millions de jeunes
français qui ne sont pas footballeurs
professionnels qui travaillent et qui
dès le moment où ils travaillent sont
massacrés par l'impôt fiscalement et ont
dû s'installer alors impossible et pas
sur les plus modestes seront nous le
ferons pour les moins de 30 ans pour
garder les jeunes en france et qu'il y
ait des moments de ce 81% veulent partir
travailler à l'étranger la réindexation
des retraites bon je vois qu'elle vous
avez échappé dans le programme de marine
le pen c'est le trader qui veut renoncer
non non il n'y aura pas que vos amis qui
ont prévu est difficile
falloir se les l'indexation des
retraites la demi part des des veuves et
des veufs qui sera réinstaurée pour
redonner du pouvoir d'achat des gens
peuvent à nos anciens tout ça ce sont
des mesures pérennes gravé dans le
marbre qu'il faut que les favoris
mentation pourront se projeter dans
l'avenir ce qu'ils ne peuvent plus faire
aujourd'hui à la mairie dans une
politique aujourd'hui qui amène les
français à se dire tiens par des qu'est
ce que je vais devenir la semaine
prochaine et ça psychologiquement les
français n'en peuvent plus et
pourtant ça n'est bien sûr c'est un
débat important mais ce n'est pas la
vérité de ce que vous faites
la mesure de 10% pour la source des
proposons c'est seront demain mais
aujourd'hui nous vous faites un
programme bon vous avez adhérents qui
n'est pas financé ce qui va arriver mais
sujet aucun problème à défendre ce qu'on
a fait sur le pouvoir d'achat y compris
sa logique profonde parce que encore une
fois le meilleur chose se crée des
emplois c'est pas de faire croire qu'on
a nous baguette magique on finance pas
son programme et que on arrose tout le
monde riche ou pas riche est-ce que la
tva c'est ça l'impôt sur le revenu ça
sera ça aussi c'est pas la question et
qu'il y avait ma p c'est la question de
gens qui sont riches tant mieux pour eux
mais qui vont bénéficier massivement
coups de milliards dos de votre mesure
pour les moins de 30 ans que vous juste
aller c'est vrai vous êtes secrétaire
d'état aujourd'hui donc vous connaissez
les affaires de l'état probablement
mieux que la moyenne des gens vous savez
aussi que aujourd'hui le poids de la tva
sur les foyers les plus modestes et des
foyers des classes moyennes le poids la
tva est double par rapport aux français
les plus aisés c'est à dire que dans
leurs dépenses ils considèrent donc en
premier donc une d une mesure sur la tva
aidera bien évidemment beaucoup plus les
foyers les plus modestes la tva étant
l'impôt probablement une justice injuste
donc la baisse de la tva réduit les
injustices je me permettait d'apporter
cette précision et on va en parler
clairement que j'avais donné la parole
est-ce que c'est le point très important
puisque ce qui préoccupe l'est de la
aujourd'hui c'est le carburant et c'est
l'énergie nous sommes je crois d'accord
sur ce point donc vous êtes d'accord
pour baisser la tva sur l'énergie je
suis là les cinq et demi je viens je
suis d'accord c'est ce que nous faisons
déjà pour avoir des mesures de pouvoir
d'achat sur les prix de l'énergie il ya
deux inconvénients majeurs à une mesure
de tva d'abord madame le pen hier je
passe elle l'a découvert ou si elle l'a
révélé mais elle a dit qu'elle était
pour le bouclier tarifaires ont confirmé
donc sa mesure de tva elles veulent
ajouter ça n'est pas financée dans votre
programme mais admettons mais une mesure
les chèques ne dit pas ça avec mépris
pour des gens qui justement besoin
demain à chaque alimentaire ou une à
chaque inflation pas lakhdar 11
le mépris et
la bd comme on disait je ne sais pas il
n'y a rien dont les droits d'auteur oui
je n'accepte simplement soyons très
clairs c'est pas une question de chèques
c'est une question de cibler les mesures
sur ceux qui ont le plus besoin dans le
moment où c'est le plus difficile parce
que la baisse de la tva oui elle est
effectivement durable oui elle touche
tout le monde
rien ne vous empêche d'avoir une mesure
quelles qu'elles soient ciblées sur les
ménages les plus modestes pourquoi
allez-vous me donner un chèque sur mon
essence j'en ai pas besoin c'est dommage
pour utiliser les deniers publics au
moment où on a besoin justement pour
éviter une dette trop importante on pour
aider les plus fous rires expliqué poids
a fini juste là dessus mais c'est
important d'avoir un échange sur ce
point précis mais le permet je suis
juste heureux tva les autorités vers
vous pourrez répondre on échangera le
problème aussi puisqu'on a parlé
d'écologie ou dit il est question de
modèle regardons les choses à long terme
c'est quand vous baisser la tva manière
pérenne puisque c'est le mot que vous
aimez cité dans les années qui viennent
il compris parce qu'on se bat pour ça
quand les cartes grands vont commencer
un peu abc il ya un pic quellier la
situation internationale vous avez
subventionner les hydrocarbures vous
allez subventionner les prix de
l'énergie on veut essayer avec le même
argent public le faire autrement
notamment pour nos jeunes pour que vit
pas dans un monde rêvé on soutient les
ménages le véhicule électrique la
transformation écologique le pays on
accompagne les plus modestes la
rénovation des logements pour le faire
vous vous ai réunis c'est précisément un
modèle qui va nous envoyer dans le mur
nous rendre dépendants à la russie
notamment pour des années et polluer
encore davantage en plus en en faisant
méfier mais sous les français y compris
monsieur ghosn
justement on va passer on va passer à
l'écologie oui mais je sonne rapporter
ça les îles mais cette sagesse allez-y
vous m'y a autorisé
d'abord je connais peu de prisonniers
qui prennent leur voiture
or le chèque essence et les différents
chèques et du gouvernement touche aussi
les prisonniers vous m'expliquerez où
est la justice vous qui souhaitez une
répartition équitable j'ai jeté dans ces
quelques mois je pense monsieur vos moi
je pense aujourd'hui à tous ces français
à tous ces français qui tirent la langue
quand ils prennent leur voiture alors
que 75 % des déplacements en france
aujourd'hui en voiture sont des
déplacements nécessaires important pour
sa table de loisirs qu'on a baissé dans
la région monsieur dans le grand est il
y à des zones où pour trouver un emploi
il pour aller travailler il faut faire
40 kilomètres
le soir et donc vous allez expliquer à
tous ces français là que pour votre
idéologie pour faire l'histoire que ils
ont un poids dans la pollution
extrêmement important alors que très
honnêtement très honnêtement cette part
de pollution par les automobilistes est
infime aujourd'hui vous aller saccager
leur vie quotidienne nous nous sommes
contre ça pouvait nous sommes contre ça
et il nous l'assumons nous préférons
nous favoriser le localisme produire en
france reste le gardien je parlais de
lire emerson qui prend sa voiture ce qui
est juste le 25 avril je pense vous les
mâles écologie tarifaire la tva ça
prendra des mois et vous allez installer
pour des années en me donnant à chaque
essence mois qu'il en ai pas besoin oui
et aux prisonniers ça c'est vous qui
avez vraiment pleuré je le répète c'est
vérifiable la transition évoluer la
transition écologique aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui peut lui c'est votre
modèle économique le modèle mondialisée
vous savez qu'en france la pollution des
gaz à effet de serre est due à 50% aux
importations président je crois qu'on
n'a pas accepté cette donnée hier il ya
eu un fact checking comme on dit en
français aujourd'hui effectivement c'est
vrai je le dis le haut conseil pour le
climat dit que sur les 12 tonnes
d'émission il y en a cinq qui viennent
des importations chutaient de -2 5
points petit peu moins de 50%
non mais je n'ai lancé je
sais pas ce qu'on fait quand on fait
venir un produit de chine il ya deux
inconvénients majeurs
d'abord ça enlève de l'emploi en france
il faut le dire et deuxièmement ça
pollue parce que les supertankers ces
énormes bateaux qui transportent les
containers pollue chacun comme des
millions d'automobiles et donc on a un
double effet négatif pour la france oui
oui cette mondialisation échevelé
polluent la planète et oui ça détruit
des emplois le modèle que propose marine
le pen c'est produisons à côté de chez
nous consommons à côté de chez nous
recyclons à côté de chez nous et là pour
le coup il y aura un double effet
positif oui on va relancer l'emploi et
oui on protégera notre environnement
mais l'environnement est le modèle
économique que vous défendez
ultralibéral ultra mondialisée des
échanges vaut sans contrôle est à la
source de la pollution et honnêtement
assumons le fait que aujourd'hui les
français dans l'ensemble de la pollution
de la pollution mondiale contribue à 0
2% les états unis 15% la chine 20% alors
trouveront une voie raisonnable en
dehors de la taxation systématique en
dehors de la culpabilisation
systématique des français qui font déjà
beaucoup d'efforts mais changeons notre
modèle pour le bien commun
j'ai entendu de choses évidemment je
vais aller même plus loin de vous la
pollution ne se règle pas comme le nuage
de tchernobyl qui ne s'arrête pas aux
frontières dans un seul pays ce n'est
pas comme ça que ça fonctionne là aussi
soyons cohérents monsieur jacques aubé
il y aura encore des échanges quand les
années qui viennent heureusement parce
qu'on n'en bénéficie aussi à l'export
beaucoup d'emplois on l'a dit en dépend
de notre pays et j'ai rappelé les
chiffres terribles notamment au niveau
de la balance commerciale oui mais je
voulais dire aux français qu'on supprime
l'export non non on va là aussi de le
renforcer non mais je vais leur dire que
justement il faut arrêter d'être
dépendant de l'intérieur l'a vu
d'ailleurs un mail à vue dans le prix
0,6 on l'a vu
dans la crise alimentaire et leur profil
que pétrole russe va être 20% de la
balance commerciale ce sont les
hydrocarbures ou va vers la souveraineté
énergétique ce qu'on est en train de
faire coter non franchement énergétique
alimentaire et sanitaire oui très bien
alors soyons cohérents arrêtons
d'importer des hydrocarbures de russie
c'est là dessus que la balance
commerciale se fait est que la pollution
ce fait nous voulons sortir des eaux
regarde mais vous croyez vraiment que si
vous allez demain après-demain dans six
mois dans deux ans limiter les échanges
avec la chine nous souhaitons le faire
aussi la chine va arrêter de polluer les
états unis vont arrêter de polluer au
contraire il faut avoir une coopération
internationale sur ce sujet le seul
moyen de défendre les accords de paris
qui ont engagé la chine les etats unis
l'arabie saoudite la turquie des gros
pollueurs pour la première fois dans une
stratégie de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet serre qu'on le fasse
justement pas tout seul c'est par
l'europe et par la coopération
internationale on pouvait pas dire à la
fois je refuse d'avoir plus d'ambition
européenne et discuter avec la chine et
états unis et vouloir traiter ce sujet
de la pollution sur la coopération je
m'inscris nationale écoute et j'ai
l'impression de n'être pas au pouvoir
parce que vous critiquer
systématiquement toutes vos propositions
il y aura le jeune effacés mais moi je
dis ça mais deux je me permets de vous
rappeler que votre bile rock aux
logiques et catastrophique d'ailleurs
vous avez été rappelé à l'ordre par les
instances internationales plusieurs fois
et je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que votre
solution oui mais que votre politique
énergétique en matière de nucléaire au
début du 4e set d'abord dans ma région
si vous faites vous avez laisser fermer
fessenheim on peut parler des 2000
emplois induits et direct
également un truc c'est extrêmement
important vous avez fermer fessenheim il
a fallu continuer à produire de
l'énergie s'est évidemment pas l'éolien
qui a subvenu aux besoins puisque
fessenheim c'est à peu près 7000
éolienne est évidemment tout cela n'est
pas raisonnable qu'est ce qu'a fait
emmanuel macron il a augmenté
l'autorisation de produits des centrales
à charbon de 50% mais de tonnes de co2
sur les rentes ai fermé voilà le bilan
réel de votre politique monsieur von
otter
fondamentale vous nous expliquer marine
le pen l'a dit le localisme n'a pas su
expliquer comment ça allait marcher mais
on est d'accord pour arrêter les accords
libre échange c'est ce qu'on a fait
justement avec les états unis où avec le
mercosur c'est notre gouvernement qu'il
a fait je suis très fier de ce bilan là
justement pour éviter le commerce
mondial dégrade le climat pour faire
simple mais soyons clairs marine le pen
elle l'a dit explicitement elle veut
ralentir le rythme la transition
écologique donc elle veut ne pas
respecter elle l a dit explicitement
donc elle ne veut pas respecter les
accords de paris la politique
énergétique c'est essentiel en effet
pour tenir nos objectifs mais là aussi
faut pas raconter des mensonges aux
français on a toujours défendu depuis le
début de ce quinquennat le nucléaire
mais vous ne ferez pas une politique de
neutralité carbone qu'avec le nucléaire
votre première centrale et vous faites
quoi d'ici 2035 ou comment vous démarrez
la tyrolienne qui sont là où démonte
l'éolienne merci de corriger vos erreurs
on prépare l'avenir en investissant
slogan suivant le niveau nucléaire on
investisse à mes 15 ans dans l'hydrogène
on relance notre
refuse de vendre nos barrages laisser ça
c'est dangereux pendant vous êtes à
l'aise laisser les autres répondent
quand même plus très salée nucléaire ça
m à 15 ans on a lancé six réacteurs vous
serez pas faire plus c'est pas une
question de pas de choix et c'est une
question industrielle repart à brno le
choix il est très simple il est en train
d'avoir des renouvelables produits en
france ou avoir des hydrocarbures
importés de l'étranger notamment de
russie vous avez fait ce deuxième choix
c'est très clair ça n'existe pas d'avoir
l'année prochaine vous demandera danse
énergétique qui exclut les éoliennes
sans recourir aux hydrocarbures donc
fait le choix soit de ralentir la
trajectoire de baisse des émissions
je comprends que c'est ce qu'a dit
marine le pen soit ou un mix des deux 2
tu es le renouvelable pour importer
davantage d'hydrocarbures il n'y a pas
d'autre option c'est pas magique la
production est restée elle se fait soit
par le nucléaire soit par l'importation
hydrocarbures soit par le renouvelable
vous ne voulez pas le renouvelable vous
voulez du nucléaire comme nous mais ça
met du temps et donc dans l'intervalle
vous faites le choix des hydrocarbures
et on arrive
pardon mais sur laurent jacot bédié
clément bonne juste un mot qu est ce que
vous dites on a trois jours du second
tour qu'est ce que vous dites ce matin
aux français pour les convaincre que
votre candidate est la meilleure pour
diriger la france cinq prochaines années
j'aimerais dire à tous nos
téléspectateurs que dimanche un choix
crucial ne vous abstenez pas ne restez
pas chez vous c'est un choix de société
un choix de civilisation
on en a pris pour cinq ans avec emmanuel
macron ne recommençons pas nous non nous
ne pouvons pas accepter la retraite à 65
ans kate une réforme injuste et qui
condamne l'avenir de ceux qui rentrent
aujourd'hui dans le monde du travail non
nous ne pouvons pas accepter que la
france soit ouverte aux quatre vents aux
importations qui ne respecte pas les
mêmes normes mais aussi disons le à des
migrations sans contrôle dont emmanuel
macron a eu le record avec les effets
que l'on connaît sur l'emploi sur les
caisses sociales et sur les sécurités il
y à un autre choix possible
ce choix c'est marine le pen pour une
france qui se retrouve une france
fraternelle une france sur une france du
pouvoir d'achat tous ceux qui ne veulent
plus des manuels macron parce qu
emmanuel macron c'est la casse sociale
parce qu emmanuel macron c'est la
division de la société parce qu emmanuel
macron c'est le mépris il l'a encore
montré hier soir et l'agora et
l'arrogance de ceux qui ont tous contre
ceux qui n'ont rien il faut changer les
choses marine le pen est prête dimanche
changeons disons au revoir et emmanuel
macron bonjour à marine le pen et
clément bonne même question qu'est ce
que vous dites aux français qui ne
regardent ce matin pour les convaincre
emmanuel macron va être élue dimanche
dimanche 24 avril c'est en effet un
choix fondamental je rejoins monsieur
jacques aubé ni sur un point il faut
aller voter l'abstention le vote blanc
ce sont des non choix il faut faire ce
choix d'abord parce que je croise a été
démontré hier qu'il y à beaucoup slogans
et de mensonges un danger de
l'extrême-droite encore dans ce pays qui
est très fort sur la rupture avec
l'europe sur la rupture avec mes
engagements écologiques sur même les
sujets qui ont été évoqués enrobé par
marine le pen sur le pouvoir d'achat en
particulier on a vu quand on regarde et
chaque mesure soit elle n'existait pas
soit elle bénéficié aux plus riches où
elles n'étaient pas financés et donc
nous sommes avec cinq ans effectivement
de pouvoir exercer nous l'assumons c'est
difficile il y ait beaucoup de crise
quand nous regardons ce que nous avons
engagé pour réformer depuis maintenant
trois ans l'hôpital public pour proposer
l'arrêt pour proposer le recrutement de
cinq autres îles infirmiers et aides
soignants pour dédoubler nos classes
dans les quartiers les plus difficiles y
compris euros monsieur jacques aubé dit
contrairement à ce qu'a dit si madame le
pen sur les engagements écologiques nous
avons déjà doublé le rythme de réduction
de nos émissions oui c'est difficile oui
quand on est aux responsabilités on se
confronte à une réalité on se confronte
à des difficultés mais nous voulons
continuer avec des ambitions plus
grandes sur les services publics sur
l'écologie sur l'europe notamment sur le
pouvoir d'achat la crise a parlé pour
nous je crois le poids qu'il en coûte
c'est une différence très clair hier
madame le pen ne voulait pas l'assumer
ou ne savaient pas que c'était ça à
cause de la dette nous avons assumé une
protection quand vous dites que nous
avons ça a été vérifié sans eau c'est la
fin vérifiez monsieur vous dit quand
vous dites que nous avons été dans un
style ultra libérale aucun pays aucun
pays d'europe et au monde n'a dépensé
autant pour protéger les plus faibles de
notre société notamment pendant la crise
moi j'en suis fier je suis fier de ce
modèle de service public de laïcité
d'engagement européen mais nous devons
encore faire plus et accélérer et merci
beaucoup merci messieurs merci d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin pour ce débat
passionnant sur le fond pense qu'on a
réussi à éclairer laissé les
téléspectateurs sur le fond de vos
projets respectifs merci beaucoup
[Musique]